this isn't good architecture nor is this
let me explain a good-sized kitchen
allows for growth
quickly one person turns into two those
two people
quickly multiply into three if not even
four
good architecture is never about the
building it's actually about the people
that use it
having an excessive amount of space for
just one person
is an overkill having stairs for
somebody that can't walk
is an oversight so how do we combat this
we need to stop
thinking about mass production
architecture one size
does not fit all nor will it ever fit
all
we need to start thinking about the
individual user
and the longevity of the architecture
itself here's an example
six months ago i ruptured my achilles
tendon in layman's terms
i broke my leg for three months i
hobbled up and down
these very stairs trying not to land on
my face
before the accident i was considered a
fit person i used to go to the gym every
single day
but it didn't matter how much upper body
strength i had
i still continued to fall on my face
multiple times and continued
to hurt myself situationally speaking
there's a front door downstairs
there is the stairs and then the entire
house is on the first floor
there is nothing on the ground floor so
how do we make good architecture this is
a very specific example that i'm giving
you guys
it's about a house that is entirely
upstairs with absolutely no
future-proofing thought behind it
we might not hurt ourselves in our lives
but we will eventually grow old so
having the entire house
upstairs just doesn't work having
potentially a simple
guest room downstairs where somebody
might stay in a situation like this
is a much better improvement than the
current situation
this kitchen for example is fit for my
purpose it isn't fit for every
purpose if you think about it it's a
small house with a very very large
kitchen
there's no overhead cupboards because
that would be wasted space
the cooktop itself is small because why
on earth would you have a 900 wide
cooktop
for a very small house the bench tops
seem excessive to most
but again it's fit for my purpose
because i utilize this space
quite often having said that this
kitchen wasn't designed by me it wasn't
designed
for me but it was carefully thought out
to be able to interpret and understand
multiple human life cycles
and to be able to provide longevity in
the architecture
that it sits in as we already know the
kitchen is the heart of every single
home so why is it that more often than
not people
cheap out or sacrifice when it comes to
the kitchen
by taking the time to design this
properly we take
bad architecture and give it longevity
eventually creating into good
useful architecture a good size kitchen
allows for growth
quickly one person turns into two those
two people
quickly multiply into three if not even
four
understanding the human life cycle is
important understanding good
architecture
but if we were to sit here all day and
just talk about the life cycle
this video would go forever so we're
going to make this
very quick as babies we require the
smallest amount of space
but if you haven't figured it out
already we quickly grow out of it
at this stage of life your parents
usually want to be very close to you
sometimes this is possible sometimes
it's not
but what we do know is it leads to side
by side bedrooms
which does become a problem later down
the track production line designs
always produce problems eventually you
want freedom and you want your own space
which consequently or not usually means
distance
regardless of the situation those spaces
will eventually become empty
so in the long run their main purpose is
going to be
to collect dust this video isn't a
solution for good architecture it's
merely there to open your eyes
you